it has been weeks since hatred mail
because of the traveling and the
vacations but we're getting back to hey
tree at mail today hey let's face it the
only logical response to guns is more
freaking guns Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom like with
most hatred males no introduction needed
whatsoever but here is a new idea the
concept of pulling me into the me to
movement and I guess hoping that I end
up having to retire from my own show
because I get caught up in it take a
listen to this can someone go all
hashtag me to on this Pakman guy please
pretty please David Pakman you are not
white and you are not a Hispanic you are
a Jew Pakman hates light-skinned
Gentiles he calls them [ __ ] and shiksas
racist two-faced Jew prick I report CNN
and Pakman says fake news on the face
box daily i I admit I've used the words
[ __ ] and shiksa in my life and every
single time it's been satirical but I
assure you not gonna happen my friend I
am NOT going to get me to because I've
not done anything worthy of being me to
do but what I have done is set up a
coupon code hey tree at 40 which saves
you 40% off of the membership of your
choice when you use the coupon code hey
tree at 40 @ww join pakman.com not only
do you save 40% while getting a hundred
percent of the member benefits 77 hey
tree it's cry and that is a really
really great thing send a middle finger
message to the hey tree it's by
supporting the david packard show use
the coupon code hey tree at 40 if you
would like